[تصفيق]
صوتها يعادل في قوته صوت صافرات سياره
الاسعاف امراه بلغاريه لقبت بصاحبه اعلى
صراخ في العالم حققت رقما يساوي تقريبا
الصوت الذي يسمع في حفله لموسيق الروك
اوركسترا سيمفونيه ودخلت موسوعه جينيس
للارقام القياسيه
موهبه الصوت الخارق
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده منه
عالم غريب
[موسيقى]
سيميليانا زهريه فنانه بلغاريا تمتلك صوتا
ليس كاي صوت اخر طبقات صوتيه فريده وغريبه
وقويه جعلت اجهزه القياس ترتجف عندما تقرا
ارقاما خارقه وخارجه عن الطبيعه لدرجه ان
موسوعه غينيس سمعت رنين صوتها فاتخذت خطوه
نحو مصدرها الصوت للوقوف على شدته
[موسيقى]
اراضوا زوجته
لا يمكن لاذن الانسان سماع صوت حدته او
قوته اعلى من خمسه
على مقياس شده الصوت فبلوغها او تجاوزها
قد يؤدي الى اصابه سامع الصوت باضرار في
اذنه لكن الزهر صوتها يتخطى عتبه 113 وهي
اعلى درجه صوت في طبقه
في سبتمبر الماضي من عام 2022
سجلت زهاريف صوتها على جهاز دقيق يقيس قوه
الصوت بعدما قال لها اصدقائها وبعض من
جمهورها انها تمتلك حنجره خارقه فوجئت
وقتها انها تخطت الحدود الصوتيه الطبيعيه
وكذا تسمى دليمه
كيف تريد استغلال قوه صوتها في رساله تفيد
البشريه كما تقول هي فلديها الاراده
للتركيز على التقنيه الشرقيه للتامل
واستكشاف الاثار العلاجيه للصوت مؤكده ان
صوتها للجميع وليس لها هي فقط
[موسيقى]
بالرغم من ان درجه صوت الفنانه البلغاريه
زهريه فوصل لحدود قوه صافرات سيارات
الاسعاف الا انه يبقى اقل بكثير من صوت
محرك طائره عند الاقلاع والذي تصل قوته
لمئه
وصوت المتفجرات والاسلحه الناريه الذي
يعادل نحو
165 ديسب
[موسيقى]